on en parle avec marianne ragots
secrétaire générale adjointe du syndicat
info'com cgt
madame rabot bienvenus merci merci
d'être là leur première question les
enjeux de cette journée montrer que vous
êtes toujours mobilisés oui évidemment
montrer les différents secteurs qui sont
mobilisés on l'a vu il y avait les
cheminots la ratp l'éducation là on l'a
vu avec les éboueurs et le centre de tri
il ya les raffineries aussi il ya les
docker il ya une grosse manifestation au
havre ghh allemand qui est organisé et
partout en france on a parlé aussi d'un
changement de stratégie donc ça c'est
des choses qui sont qui sont discutées
en ag oui justement qu'en est il à sur
ça parce qu'on le voit bien au niveau
des transports que le nombre des
grévistes diminue fortement le trafic
est beaucoup moins perturbé aujourd'hui
que par exemple le 5 décembre
est ce que justement cette baisse de la
mobilisation ne va pas un peu rassuré
l'exécutif je crois pas parce que
l'exécutif le gouvernement a joué le
pourrissement donc le pourrissement
c'est elle une stratégie mise en place
justement pour essouffler fatigué je
pense que la plupart des téléspectateurs
comprendront bien que faire 51 jours de
grève c'est déjà un record pour des gens
qui ont des salaires qui sont enfin
c'est juste financièrement ça va ça va
avoir un coût il faut aussi savoir que
ça va avoir un coût sur les sauts les
prochains mois est même sûr on peut dire
pratiquement peut-être une année pour
certains c'est un essai situe au niveau
des échéances des loyers des factures
c'est des choses très très lourde
notons enfin pour les grévistes et pour
leurs proches parce que c'est des
familles des enfants des jeunes qui font
des études et c'est donc effectivement
il ya un moment donné où ça devient
extrêmement
compliqué donc on se réorganise on
réfléchit mais la contestation elle est
dans l'air elle était déjà dans l'air
avec les gilet jaune
il nous manque il nous manque il nous
manque pas grand chose on attendait que
d'autres secteurs arrive ça c'est pas
fait ça s'est pas passé comme on
l'aurait voulu mais le mouvement
continue mais justement il ya peut-être
un niveau un peu de manque au niveau du
secteur privé alors c'est la question
qu'on se pose déjà on n'a pas là on n'a
pas toute la visibilité
en fait c'est une des conséquences en
fait du monde du travail aujourd'hui on
a des gens qui ont peur et ils ont
raison d'avoir peur parce que quand vous
avez un statut vulnérables vous avez
moins d'accès aux droits que les autres
vous êtes plus fragilisés puisqu'on peut
vous on peut vous virer plus facilement
selon vous c'est la seule raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui les salariés du
secteur privé ne sont pas dans les rues
j'ai dansé une c'est une des raisons
et puis il ya peut-être aussi des gens
qui n'imaginent pas ou qu'ils n'arrivent
pas imaginer ce qui va se passer
souvent dans les entreprises ou les
associations pour ce qui est des grands
enjeux comme ça qui touche toute la
population ils sont là on alerte
ils sont là en avant-garde pour dire
attention et souvent les gens ont dû je
pense que les gens ont du mal à imaginer
que le système de sécurité sociale
puisse être démantelé alors moi j'ai
envie de dire à ces gens là regardez ce
qui s'est passé en grèce parce qu'ils
vous avez des gens qui vous le disent
jamais on aurait cru ce qui sait ce que
ce qui allait que les que les décisions
gouvernementales de restrictions
budgétaires allaient nous conduire à une
baisse des salaires une baisse des
pensions
voilà donc nous on a prévenu maintenant
on se bat parce qu'on sait que prévenir
ne suffit pas il faut que les gens
passent le pas alors vous parlais juste
avant le changement de stratégie parce
que effectivement faire la grève
indéfiniment c'est pas forcément
possible pour les salariés un changement
de stratégie qui va être décidé en
assemblée générale est ce que vous savez
justement quel va être l'avenir de ces
grèves
personne ne peut le savoir
personne ne peut prédire personne ne
pouvait prédire qu'on allait aller sur
la bonne surprise je pense pour
l'ensemble du mouvement social et c'est
que on n'y a pas eu de trêve comme il
avait été dit donc le mouvement a tenu
il peut se passer
il peut se passer n'importe quoi la
seule chose qu'on sait c'est qu'en face
on a un bulldozer néolibérale là qui
aujourd'hui est incarnée par macron mais
qui pourrait être incarnée par quelqu'un
d'autre et c'est le dénoncent le
démantèlement de la sécurité sociale et
des conditions très alors très
rapidement le projet de lancer présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres ce
que c'est pas un message clair de la
part de l'exécutif qui veut vous faire
comprendre qu'il ira jusqu'au bout mais
bien mais bien sûr mais c'est tout le
temps comme ça dans les entreprises
c'est pareil quand on prend une décision
on vous dit on déjà d'emblée on vous dit
ce sera comme ça en psycho logiquement
on vous invite déjà à
à rendre à rendre les armes donc
évidemment mais ça c'est leur stratégie
mais bon je pense que les mouvements
sociaux les gens en ont suffisamment
d'expérience il suffit de regarder un
peu dans les livres d'histoire pour
savoir comment ça se passe effectivement
le moral c'est important il faut garder
le moral
marraine bravo merci d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint du syndicat
info'com cgt ma merci de votre
invitation